et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
sophie cluzel bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin secrétaire
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
en détention pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour mascate
jalabert du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on va
bien sûr parler de vos dossiers sont
nombreux sophie cluzel mais d'abord un
mot sur l'actualité on en parlait au
début de cette émission cette marche
blanche inerte dans les rues de mulhouse
en mémoire de dina cette adolescente
lycéenne de 14 ans qui s'est suicidée
victimes de harcèlement scolaire selon
ses proches est ce que le gouvernement
fait assez dans la lutte contre le
harcèlement scolaire à sète une des
vraies priorités 1 de l'ensemble du
gouvernement que ce soit du ministre
jean michel blanquer de moi même parce
que le harcèlement je voudrais rappeler
quand même le handicap est une des
premières causes de harcèlement donc on
travaille main dans la main c'est un
fléau c'est un fléau ça peut détruire
des vies on le voit bien détruire des
familles détruire des adolescents à 7h
si fragile donc il faut faire feu de
tout bois on s'appuie aussi sur les
associations qui font un très très beau
boulot au sein des écoles des collèges
des lycées donc oui je pense que nos
âmes et les chiffres sur ces questions
de harcèlement on le voit en tout les
élèves sont touchés par cette question
du harcèlement de toutes catégories dans
tout dans toutes les régions est ce que
par exemple les élèves handicapés sont
plus victimes de harcèlement que les
autres et ce que vous avez des chiffres
et non j'ai pas de chiffres très précis
mais ça la parole commence à circuler et
ça c'est important il faut la libérer
cette parole et quand vous creusez oui
ils ont toujours été victime de
harcèlement ou de moqueries sans aller
jusqu'au harcèlement en tout cas de mots
qui blessent énormément donc on
travaille beaucoup là dessus sur les
mots qui blessent c'est un travail
incessant c'est un travail avec eux ces
jeunes ambassadeurs qui circulent dans
les écoles dans les collèges dans les
lycées partout il faut en parler il faut
libérer la parole et puis après c'est
zéro tolérance c5 et qui va nous changer
la donne notamment dans l'éducation
nationale s'il ne pleuvait pas que dans
les centres sportifs dans les écoles de
loisirs dans l'est dans les écoles
partout il faut pouvoir faire circuler
cette farol et en parler un autre mot
sur l'actualité du côté de marseille
c'est une ville que vous connaissez bien
évidemment se méfier cluzel didier août
est accusé d'avoir mené des essais
cliniques sauvage contre la tuberculose
mettant en danger les patients le
protocole qu'il a utilisée n'était pas
autorisée par les autorités sanitaires
il est entraîné de graves complications
chez plusieurs patients qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette affaire écoutez je
pense que les affaires sont en cours je
me permettrai pas de commenter des
affaires en cours mais il faut là aussi
là aussi il faut vraiment appliqués les
contrôles c'est très important surtout
on a des recommandations de bonne
pratique de la haute autorité de santé
il faut qu'elles s'appliquent partout ce
dans tous les domaines donc ça je fais
confiance justement la justice au
ministre de la santé pour bouder raul
qui alors pas sur cette question bien
évidemment mais qu'il débute début de la
crise on le voit est soutenue par
plusieurs élus notamment du côté de l'as
de la région sud coup pensez quoi de ce
soudain je pense que voilà il faut
peut-être revoir aussi ce genre de
soutien quand on a des faits et appuyons
nous sur les faits et non pas sur les
rumeurs je pense que c'est le plus
important l'assistance publique des
hôpitaux de marseille se réserve la
possibilité de saisir le parquet de
marseille elle doit le faire pour vous
je pense que le ciel si elle décide de
le faire bien sûr on va parler de vos
dossiers maintenant sophie cluzel et on
va peut-être commencer par le baromètre
sur les maisons départementales
voilà du que nous révélons donc chemin
taisne à nos colonnes et qui fait
apparaître des inégalités dans le
traitement des dossiers d'un département
à l'autre alors sophie cluzel comment en
est on arrivé là et qu'allez vous faire
pour y remédier on en est arrivé là
puisque depuis la loi de 2005 et bien on
n'a pas imposé un système informatique
on n'a pas travaillé sur une uniformité
des droits ouverts pour les personnes
handicapées alors homme pour être précis
n dans certains départements deux mois
une personne handicapée obtient ses
droits et dans d'autres départements il
faut jusqu'à neuf mois voilà mais ça
c'est inacceptable c'est bien pour ça
qu'on a pris le taureau par les cornes
que j'ai travaillé que l'association des
départements de france depuis 2010 est
et que nous avons fait une grande
feuille de route mdph 2022 il faut
peut-être rappeler que ce sont les
présidents de département qui gère ces
maisons départementales des personnes
handicapées et qui sont donc en pleine
responsabilité avec l'état bien sûr
puisque nous avons des services de
l'état aussi dans ses équipes et je
pense que ce qui est important de dire
c'est que qu'est-ce qu'il nous faut
faire simplifier la vie des personnes
handicapées depuis 2010 9 nous avons des
droits à vie ça veut dire quoi plus
besoin d'aller chez le toubib tous les
trois ans pour tamponner son certificat
midi cal et dire je suis toujours
aveugle doublement peut-être aux
trisomiques c'est insupportable depuis
2010 neuf il ya la possibilité
d'octroyer ces droits vie est bien dans
certains départements dans certains
maisons départementales on n'est pas au
niveau de ce que l'on peut espérer en
moyenne nationale on est entre 65 et 70%
en dans l'ensemble des maisons pour cet
octroi droit vie et puis il ya des
grandes des grosses département qui n'y
sont pas ou même des petits je prends
paris par exemple 58 % seulement de
droit à vie mais pourquoi bon sens doit
depuis 2019 on n'a pas massivement pris
ce problème à bras le corps et les
octroyer c'est du gagnant gagnant les
équipes renouvelle de la même façon on
perd du temps c'est indigne pour les
personnes de devoir toujours retrouver
leur handicap et puis c'est la faute des
départements des précisé l'avoir
demandée et laisse d'organisation qui ne
sont pas mises en place je pense qu'il
faut vraiment s'emparer de ce problème
et moi je fais un appel à tous les
départements vous êtes chef de file des
politiques de solidarité il faut y aller
à fond c'est du gagnant un service
public doit être équitable sur
l'ensemble du territoire ça marche dans
des grandes département dans le nord on
y est à plus de 80% donc c'est pas un
problème de taille c'est un problème d'
implication du chef de file des
départements et d'y aller à fond et je
serai tout à l'heure donc dans la somme
avec le président au soulier qui a été
nommé responsable du handicap au sein du
nouvel exécutif de l'association des
départements de france j'ai reçu le
président sauvadet il est aligné
exactement là dessus il faut y aller à
fond
mais l'état ne naît pas que incantatoire
je rappelle qu'on a remis 25 millions
sur la table justement pour accompagner
les mdph qui n'était pas au niveau de
l'informatique donc maintenant qu'on a
mis cet argent qu'on a cette feuille de
route il faut y aller à fond et je serai
vraiment intraitable sur le prochain
baromètre à la fin de cette année il
faut conseils qu'on soit tous au même
niveau intraitable ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir challenge
chaque département c'est ce que je fais
je tourne partout en france j'ai tant
d'hommes j'étais dans la creuse j'étais
dans l'aveyron pas plus tard que la
semaine dernière maintenant si vous avez
des gros problèmes informatiques la cns
à la caisse nationale de solidarité
d'autonomie est à vos côtés mais nous
faut des résultats et qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire est ce que par exemple
signature pas de résultats sur le
prochain baromètre vous pouvez vous êtes
en mesure de faire quoi des sanctions la
sanction financière non y'aura pas
l'appui financier comme on le fait donc
des sanctions financières afin là dessus
d'un gers voilà celle inverse
aujourd'hui on vient aux côtés j'ai
resigné avec le président trou seine en
seine saint denis 1 million d'ha puis 17
personnes qui peuvent eux qui ont été
embauchés pour venir en appui il faut
qu'on ait des résultats autre dossier
qui vous tient à coeur et puis surtout
qui est important dans le ministère
c'est la scolarisation il semblerait que
la sortie du cow boys on manque
d'accompagnants au moins que demandeur
pour aider les enfants à aller
handicapés aller à l'école alors là
aussi sur ce dossier depuis 2010 est on
à 20% de plus d'élèves handicapés
scolarisés
on a un vrai chemin vers l'école de
façon naturelle maintenant pour les
enfants prennent un peu plus de la
moitié des enfants ont besoin d'être
accompagnés je dis bien un peu plus de
la moitié d'autres ont besoin de
matériel pédagogique d'adaptation
d'emploi du temps pour ceux qui ont
besoin d'être accompagnés 35% de plus
d'augmentation d'effectifs depuis 2010
est on est passé de 70 mille
accompagnant d'élèves en situation
d'handicap à plus de 125 mille
aujourd'hui ils sont tous en contrat
éducation nationale rappelons-nous en
2017 60% d'entre eux étaient en contrat
aidé dis moi au bout de 10 mois il
n'était plus là il re devait reporter à
la chômage c'est fini ça ils sont tous
en contre et éducation nationale alors
et on embauche encore 4000 accompagnant
à la rentrée scolaire dont qui c'est
vrai qu'il ya une demande forte mais moi
je dis que la solution c'est ce dans
plusieurs leviers les accompagnants bien
formés à aux côtés de l'élève si ça a
été notifié par les maisons du handicap
mais surtout la coopération médico
social il faut qu'on ouvre massivement
la porte des écoles au psy comme au tri
siens aux orthophonistes pour que tout
se passe dans l'école c'est ce qu'on a
fait sur les classes autistes sur les
classes autistes ou non près de 300
classes maternelles autistes tout se
passe dans l'école les enfants sont à
temps plein les parents retravaille et
cette coopération avec le regard des
spécialistes et des enseignants et des
accompagnants c'est comme ça qu'on y
arrivera tous ensemble une formation
initiale des enseignants seront enfin
obligatoire intense dans les cordes on a
l'impression que les choses vont plutôt
bien vraiment bio elles vont beaucoup
mieux ils se sont mobilisés ces
accompagnants dès l'âge en situation de
handicap vous les avez évidemment
entendu dans la rue plusieurs choses
d'abord ils se plaignent d'un manque de
reconnaissance ils ont l'impression de
ne pas être assez reconnus par l'état je
pense qu'ils sont entièrement reconnu
ils font un métier extraordinaire et ce
sont des gens formidables je connais
bien ce dossier depuis des années et des
années je pense que leur statut a changé
le ministre de l'éducation nationale à
la mi vraiment dans le dialogue social
ils font partie de la communauté
éducative qui n'était pas le cas après
j'entends qu'il ya parfois des problèmes
de précarité financière
ça c'est un chalet reynard deuxième
chose
10010 cantine sont en contrats à temps
plein j'allais dire qu'il est une touche
à peine le smic et beaucoup y ait
beaucoup n'ont pas leurs heures donc non
pas 32 eur voire voire 35 heures et donc
ils sont à sept cent mille 100 euros par
mois exact que vous les entendez mais
bien sûr qu'on les entend c'est pour ça
qu'on est en train d'essayer de changer
les choses il y à peu près 10% déjà
qu'ils sont cdi puisque je vous rappelle
ont fait 3 ans puis trois ans et cdi
certains sont déjà à temps plein 30 35
heures quand il ya justement une
possibilité au collège au lycée d'avoir
ce nombre d'heures parce que on est en
élémentaire on n'a que 24 heures de
temps écoles pour autant certains même
en hebdo en école élémentaire peuvent
être à un message accompagnant
ressources avec donc voilà on essaie de
travailler là dessus pour améliorer leur
temps on travaille aussi beaucoup avec
les collectivités locales parce que
quand on est enfant handicapé parfois on
a besoin d'être accompagné aussi à la
cantine au centre de loisirs pour aller
faire de la culture du sport ou accéder
à la culture donc on a la possibilité
d'offrir un temps complet c'est les
métiers de demain ses accompagnants ils
font un travail formidable et je tiens
vraiment à l'or alors allé saluer parce
que c'est un métier que j'ai porté
depuis très longtemps il est parfois
indispensable mais ce n'est pas un
préalable à la scolarisation je tiens à
le dire aussi lors de l'autre chose
c'est qu'il ya une réforme qui a été
mise en place qui met en place des pôles
inclusive c'est à dire qu'il ya une
mutualisation de ses accompagnants et il
dit du coup on se retrouve à s'occuper
de cinq six sept élèves en même temps
c'est la solution une mobilisation des
enseignants le pôle d'inclusion
d'accompagnants localiser c'est le fait
d'avoir des pôles en collèges qu'en
lycées en école au plus près des
territoires ça je tiens vraiment elle
dirait retour à gérer plusieurs élèves
en même temps est-ce que les gens tant
d'égards et compliqué il ya déjà il ya
toujours eu des élèves d accompagnement
auprès de plusieurs élèves ça dépend du
besoin il ya deux façon d'accompagner
soit c'est soutenu et continue parce que
l'enfant est extrêmement a besoin de cet
accompagnement soit il a besoin sur des
temps et on organise le temps de travail
après on entend les difficultés je ne le
nie pas il faut qu'on améliore la
formation conjointe avec les enseignants
les accompagnant le médico social mais
on y travaille en tout cas le ministre
de l'éducation nationale l'a vraiment
inscrits dans sa feuille de route
prioritaire il a travaillé sur une
grille indiciaire pour améliorer leurs
conditions de rémunération
la formation des 60 heures et en
augmente encore le dernier mot la tuer
ce cas pas un problème dans le système
vous le dit ce sont les maisons
départementales qui accorde 16 heures et
qui définissent les besoins de l'enfant
et vous nous l'avez dit sur mon contrat
éducation nationale ça veut dire que
c'est l'éducation nationale qui les
financent est-ce que là il n'y a pas un
problème mais justement on l'a enfin la
loi la fête au sein de la maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
pour qu'ils aient une objectivation du
besoin et que ça soit pas liée aux
moyens donc au contraire mais par contre
là où il faut qu'on travaille mieux
c'est sur cette coopération je leur dis
haut et fort il faut que les portes de
l'école s'ouvre aux professionnels et
que tout se passe dans l'enceinte de
l'école pour que les parents puissent
retravaillé c'est notre objectif un mot
un peu plus largement on a beaucoup
entendu parler du ségur de la santé qui
a revalorisé
effectivement les soignants est ce que
les personnes qui travaillent auprès des
personnes handicapées n'ont pas été un
peu oubliée des majeurs du gouvernent
n'ont pas été oubliés la preuve en est
c'est que justement nous remettons près
de 400 millions pour ses personnels
médico social dans les établissements
qui accueillent des personnes
handicapées enfants aux adultes à partir
du 1er janvier 2022 les 183 euros nets
seront généralisées à l'ensemble des
personnels en revanche je ne nie pas les
problèmes de recrutement lors du gp nury
la pénurie mais non généraliser la
pénurie dans certains territoires savage
et et dans l'aveyron vendredi il n'y a
pas trop de problème de pénurie dans
d'autres il ya énormément de tensions
dans ce métier alors bien sûr qu'il ya
une part comme vous l'avez dit très
justement sur la prime ségur mais qui va
arriver et je tiens vraiment à dire
qu'il ya des associations qui l'ont déjà
versés parce que pendant la crise est
bien la trésorerie a était intacte
auprès de ces associations puisque
l'état était à leurs côtés pour
l'ensemble ça va être généralisé au 1er
janvier mais au-delà de ça il nous faut
réfléchir sur l'attractivité de ses
métiers il faut qu'on travaille sur les
passerelles possibles sur les formations
sur la reconnaissance de ses métiers sur
la capacité justement pouvoir évoluer
d'un monde à l'autre entre le domicile
les établissements c'est un vrai sujet
majeur de demain et d'aujourd'hui mais
surtout de demain comment attirer les
jeunes sur ce métier comment former tout
au long de la vie pour pouvoir faire
traverser justement les différents murs
que peuvent être les cols je vous
rappelle qu'un diplôme d'état
d'accompagnants éducation et social peut
être fait à l'école au domicile à
l'établissement c'est un enjeu majeur et
je suis tous les jours avec les
associations justement pour pallier à
ces difficultés parce qu'il en va
vraiment de l'accueil digne et
respectueux des personnes en situation
de handicap oui donc dans les autres
dossiers qui ont pas mal fâché c'est
cette fameuse des conjugale isation 2
l'allocation adulte handicapé en gros
c'est calculé sur le couple et non plus
sur la personne que répondez-vous aux
associations qui alors un dessus au bas
non plus c'est parlons pas c'est n'ont
pas sonné enfin on hérite d'une
situation qui existe depuis 1987 l'a75
la création de l'allocation adulte
handicapé qui est un minima comme tous
les minimas et sont calculés bien sûr à
partir des revenus du conjoint comme
tous les minima donc c'est ce que j'ai
redit devant les associations mais de
vente n 1 puisque le sénat a voté en
faveur de celle des coûts oui c'est vrai
bien sûr alors qu'en 2018 il voté contre
je tiens à rappeler qu'ils ont voté
contre tout des conjugale isation
jusqu'en 2018 et brusquement ils votent
pour autant expliquer la logique est la
colonne vertébrale
tout ça évidemment de la part du sénat
évidemment et de la part aussi de
l'assemblée nationale et d'aurélien
pradié également puisque s'est passé à
l'assemblée nationale d'ailleurs je
rappelle que dans le lot on n'est qu'à
30 % d'octroi des droits vis donc ils
feraient mieux de s'occuper de son
territoire plutôt que de donner des
leçons à tout le monde ça c'est la bo
département d'aurélien pradié exactement
je sais pas lui qui n'ont pas d'argent
et qu'il aille qu'il aille voir qu'il
est challengé son président département
pour autant jeu pour revenir à ça ce que
je dis moi c'est qu'il nous faut et
c'est ce que les associations vont
porter puisque le conseil national
consultatif des personnes handicapées
ouvre les assises sur les ressources des
personnes handicapées parce qu'il faut
voir ça dans sa globalité la fiscalité
les ressources et donc nous allons
travailler ensemble pour voir l'ensemble
de la situation ouvrons aussi le débat
sur les autres minima sociaux sur le rsa
sur l'apa sur la location pour la perte
d'autonomie qui sont calculées de la
même façon donc oui c'est un vrai sujet
de société que peut-on faire à travers
notre cinquième branche de l'autonomie à
venir de l'allée des ressources des
personnes et de la compensation parce
que la compensation du handicap c'est la
prestation de compensation du handicap
qui elle est individualisé mais ça veut
dire parce que c'était votre argument
devant le sénat que si on le fait pour
pour la location du temps du cap et il
faut le faire pour le rsa pour la paille
que donc ça va coûter des milliards à
l'état donc vous ne des milliards il
faut poser le débat pour ne pas le faire
uniquement pour cette allocation adulte
ou bien est ce que ce sont des citoyens
à part où des citoyens à part entière
mais voulait les entendais ces
associations vous les avez vus comme on
est allé faire des reportages ya des
gens qui sont obligés de divorcer pour
continue pour se remettre à alger à ces
gens là est ce que vous avez bien la
prestation de compensation du handicap
qui elle est individualisé et chaque
fois que j'ai un peu creuse et n'ont
donc c'est le recours il est là le droit
il est dans la compensation individuelle
et après dans la dans la fête mais
qu'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai réagi
immédiatement puisque dans le projet de
loi de finances et portait un abattement
à 5000 euros pour remonter justement la
capacité quand on est dans un couple de
continuer à toucher son allocation
adulte handicapé bien sûr que je les
entends et bien sûr que je travaille
avec les associations
1 depuis qu'on parle d' allocation alors
pas de l'allocation adulte handicapé
mais hier eric zemmour il a proposé de
réserver les allocations rsa
l'allocation logement les allocations
sociales aux français uniquement il dit
que la solidarité nationale doit
s'appliquer à la nation et que les
allocations sociales doivent être
accordés aux étrangers même en situation
régulière qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé moi je pense qu'on est on a
vraiment un sens ne recueillir de la
façon dont on traite les personnes les
personnes les plus vulnérables les
personnes handicapées notamment et que
quand il ya une urgence on est toujours
là la france est toujours là aux côtés
de ceux qui en ont le plus besoin et que
quand de toute façon il y à une
régularisation automatique qui se fait
qu'on ouvre des droits une personne
handicapée arrivent sur notre territoire
et bien tout de suite on est là à côté
d'elle on ouvre ses droits et après bien
sûr y est la régularisation du fait de
sa situation donc je pense qu'il faut
arrêter ce débat c'est un faux débat sur
ce que mais ce candidat je peux si on
peut l'appeler candidats sous polémiste
sur la table regardons plutôt qu'est ce
qu'on veut faire pour accompagner les
personnes à trouver du travail les
accompagner à trouver un logement les
accompagner dignement une fois qu'on a
accueilli les personnes à être vraiment
complètement intégré dans notre société
en respectant leur différence c'est le
mettant tout cas c'est le le projet de
société que je porte moi c'est un
s'enrichir de la différence faire en
sorte que ces différences ou est
acceptée et cons et qu'on travaille sur
eric zemmour il va trop long il va plus
loin que marine le pen à qui elle
propose de réserve location aux
étrangers qui justifie de cinq ans de
travail à temps complet sur le
territoire lui va plus loin dit qu'aucun
étranger doit les percevoir ce sont ceux
son droit il peut dire ce qu'il veut et
va trop loin pour vous je pense qu'il
dit ce qu'il veut comment le travail et
après avec ces étrangers qui apporte
justement leur pierre à l'édifice pour
beaucoup d'entre eux je pense qu'il faut
qu'on regarde ça de façon un peu
différente un dernier mot sur vos
dossiers avant une question politique de
pascal selon l'ifop il ya un handicapé
sur deux qui embauchent en entreprise et
qui se dit victime de discrimination en
parler sur la question du harcèlement
scolaire en début d'émission dans les
entreprises c'est un petit peu la même
chose est ce que pour vous il faut
durcir les quotas de personnes
handicapées en entreprise sur sert à
rien dire sur des quotas les côtés il
existe depuis 1987 à 6 % net à 3 8% en
moyenne dans le privé bien ça
l'essentiel
il faut surtout accompagner les
entreprises qui me disent nos voudrait
bien on trouve pas dans du sourcing
c'est pour ça qu'on fait le duo d encore
une fois 4e édition le 18 novembre j'en
fais un appel à tous le duo des c'est un
jour une personne justement travailler
avec une personne handicapée ça marche
parce que ça permet de faire 10% des
duos de l'année dernière était en
sourcing c'est-à-dire ont été embauchés
derrière il faut passer de l'obligation
à l'envi il faut simplifier la politique
on a trop longtemps été politique de
spécialistes là il faut dans le droit
commun pour c'est pour ça qu'avec eux la
ministre du travail on a rapproché pôle
emploi cap emploi une seule porte
d'entrée pour les entreprises une seule
porte d'entrée pour les personnes et
celles qui ont besoin d'être accompagnés
on à l'emploi accompagné on a parlé de
l'école accompagnés ont fait long feu
maintenant l'emploi accompagner le job
coaching pour les handicaps psychiques
le déficience cognitive celles qui sont
difficiles rappelle que 80% des
handicaps sont invisibles
donc il faut accompagner beaucoup plus
et ça fonctionne la baisse du chômage
pour les personnes handicapées est une
réalité en ce moment ça prouve bien que
tout ce qu'on a mis en place depuis 2010
est d'accompagnement et je permettais
moi juste de rappeler l'aide à l'emploi
4000 euros dada l'emploi pour tous cdd
depuis trois mois et cdi vingt mille
contrats signés déjà 70 % en cdi donc on
voit bien aussi quand une incitation
financière ça fonctionne ena questions
politiques parce que oui donc vous
appartenez majorité autant 2017 on
voyait bien comment le mouvement était
impulser la rm annuel manqueront avec
les marcheurs autant là c'est un peu fou
il ya le mot alors philippe il ya les
marcheurs il y a quelle histoire de
trouver une branche gauche ne branche
grotte comment voyez cela vous pour pour
lancer une campagne mais je pense que
c'est bien ça prouve qu'il ya une
pluralité de courants qui vont se
rassembler derrière le président s'il
faut faire une maison commune avec
toujours c'est ce qu'on a déjà fait
depuis 2010 est une maison commune et
c'est une réalité sur les territoires
quand pendant pendant les élections
régionales moi je l' ai bien vu que
cette maison commune c'est une réalité
avec le groupe modem agir territoire de
progrès en marche elle existe déjà fall
a fédéré de façon un peu plus large et
puis voilà il faut être derrière
j'espère le président s'il se présente
il faut bien dit que la rapidement en
tout cas moi mon parti c'est le
président de toute façon et je serai je
serai derrière lui à fond comme depuis
2010 est merci beaucoup merci
s'affichent les ailes d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin
[Musique]